from nick uh-oh
nick we've missed nick hey michael me
again i'm sorry for being m.i.a the past
few months i've been on a spiritual
journey
so apparently there's this thing called
ayahuasca long story short i fell off my
king energy and was seduced by another
goddess who loves crystals i was
listening to joe rogan and got really
into the beatles none of which i'm proud
of after i lost track of sydney in tulum
and made it back to the states i
couldn't shake the ayahuasca trip i felt
like i saw and spoke to other beings it
was nuts do you think ayahuasca and dmt
make you hallucinate or finally see
what's already there as a spiritual dude
who doesn't do drugs i figured you could
tell me what's up this is actually a
good question nick and i get this from a
lot of people
they'll say hey man you know i don't i'm
not religious or nothing i'm not one of
you crazy christians or nothing you know
but i do a bunch of drugs and i and i
see lots of spirits man you know and i
so i believe in that you know i think oh
so you believe in demons okay you don't
believe in angels and god but you do
believe in demons okay i don't do drugs
i've never been into drugs the the
hardest drug i've ever had was a puffer
two on the old haitian oregano but it
does not interest me because i i don't
want brain damage and i think i rely on
my brain i think it's working okay right
now and if i want to explore
metaphysical questions like you're
talking about i would like to do it in a
way that is rigorous that is not that
does not involve me losing control of my
rational faculties and my will like you
do when you do drugs but that actually
focuses my intellectual faculties and my
and my will
on things like philosophy and theology
that applies intellectual rigor to all
of these questions so what are people
seeing when they take ayahuasca or dmt
or whatever other mushrooms or acid what
are they seeing
well
they could be hallucinating probably
that's a big part of it but also
we there is more between heaven and
earth than is dreamt of as in our
philosophies horatio also there is a
spiritual reality to the world there are
angels and there are demons and there is
spiritual battle and there's good and
bad and right and wrong and we're in
that and we we are bodies but we're also
souls and so that that stuff is real
and when you
lose control of your intellect and your
will you open yourself up to a lot of
potentially pretty nasty things and that
that's that's real i mean we talk about
spirits you know forget about ayahuasca
for a second let's say you just go out
and you drink too much
you're opening yourself up by drinking a
lot of spirits you are opening yourself
up in a way to spirits because you're
you're no longer as in control of your
will so long and short nick is
don't do drugs buddy
go to church
right now go to all form dot slash
knowles i've told you about how great
the helix mattress is i've told you
about that for years well helix has a
new company it's called all form helix
is leaving the bedroom they're going
into the living room in the family room
they have got phenomenal sofas not only
are they extremely high quality
aesthetically in terms of the materials
but also they're just very very cool the
way it works with all form sofas is you
can pick
what an armchair a love seat up to an
eight seat sectional you can pick your
fabric you can pick the sofa color you
can pick the leg color the sofa size the
sofa shape and then
you can grow the sofa as your home grow
so if you're in a studio apartment right
now you can start with a really small
one and you can add on as you grow it's
phenomenal they've got a 100 day decide
if you want to keep it guaranteed
so if you don't like it they'll come
it's no big deal you can send it back
not a problem
they'll pick it up for free they'll give
you a full refund they've also got a
forever warranty forever warranty so
right now to find your perfect sofa go
to allform.com
knowles all form is offering 20 off all
orders for our listeners allforum.com
knowles i'm so glad you liked that clip
if you want more clips head on over and
subscribe ring that bell you'll get many
more clips go subscribe to the michael
knowles show too we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you